[Música]
es un orgullo para nosotros hacer este
puente como lo has visto del trabajo
en comunidad Unión hacer la fuerza que
hacemos todos no es como le digo
retroceder en el tiempo no hacer el
cuento
si comparamos solamente con la ejecución
del puente que hoy está hecho esta
carretera o esta vía que nos trae como
acceso ha demorado casi un año pero este
cuento nosotros lo ejecutamos en tres
días es una gran demostración Así como
nos han dejado este legado nuestros
antepasados que realmente este puente sí
es resistente
nos han dejado los abuelos y aquellos
tiempos entonces amigos achaca yo
aprecio bastante por eso es uno de los
tornillos yo trabajo en la en la derecha
o coyana no y mi hijo trabaja también en
el lado caballa
[Música]